we have a three-season since you are off
walking dead people are still mad that
you're off the show do you still get
people that come up to you and kind of
show their show there they're mad I
think it was an impactful moment so back
to it I'm just uh grateful for it I'm
grateful that the character got to leave
on such a high note and it's really cool
so watch episodes I do keep up with the
plot I do yeah absolutely I want to see
my friends keep in touch with them
absolutely for the best et spoke with
Steven Yeun at the New York City
premiere of his new Netflix film Opa Opa
is a Korean name but it's like an old
female classic name so the equivalent in
a way might be like Harriet or like
Georgina
or something like that which kind of
gives you a little bit more glimpse into
a tone of the film we are animal lovers
our plan is to expose Miranda rescued
Pope Joe bring her back to you
what was it like working with Brad Pitt
I know he's exactly a priest on this
film how hands-on was he um Brad is a
wonderful producer
he's pretty Brad Pitt II he's awesome
yeah he's amazing yeah what's the best
thing about working with Brad Perry's
rep it is just looking at Brad Pitt yeah
you staring at him all day long yeah
[Music]
you